Chase Chrisley takes his mind off the
family's crisis as parents Todd and
Julie serve their combined 19-year
prison sentence in one word describe
what it means to be a part of the
Chrisley family love blessed blessed and
clearly in love has Chase packs on the
PDA with fiance Emmy medors check out
the Chrisley Knows Best star out in
Miami with his longtime love the couple
who got engaged last October taken the
Rays and waves sharing a kiss during an
ocean dip relationships are hard work
but I finally found someone that I'm
willing to put that hard work in for us
over on the gram Emmy called The Magic
City getaway a weekend that was good for
the soul she posted these pics with
Chase who's looking more and more like
his dad you're everything that Julie and
I have dreamed of okay you remember our
deal you said you weren't going to be
extra and the dials kind of turning of
course the vacay comes as both father
and son are navigating tough times what
we will not do is we will not break for
Chase it's carrying on with life while
his parents are behind bars following
Mom and Dad's convictions for bank fraud
and tax evasion any family who faces a
loved one going to prison
um it's a very difficult challenge
that's true for this family but they're
strong they're faithful and I think
they'll continue in in that way forward
as for Emmy Todd and Julie's future
daughter-in-law her family life
struggles have helped put things in
perspective for the Chrisleys you're in
a completely different boat right and I
don't know how you do it like I
absolutely by the grace of God I'm not
even kidding I think that I I have
raised thanking children for that I'm
blessed Amy's father lives with ALS also
known as Lou Gehrig's Disease which
affects the nervous system everyone's
pain is relevant to what they're going
through right so our pain for us is
devastating but I had to look at my kids
and say snap out of it it could be worse
is anyone in this room not paying
attention that Emmy may not have her dad
next Christmas having our family
together no matter what we go through
we're going to go through it together
and I know that they've always got my
back and I've always got there right
when my dad got diagnosed I wanted to
quit work I was like I'm quitting I'm
not working I'm going home I'm gonna
spend every day with you like I don't
care about anything I'm I'm going home
and my dad's like Emmy you can't do that
you can't just stop yeah what you're
doing you have to live your life well
Emmy's clearly taking her dad's advice
soaking up the sun with her hubby to be
as for the Chrisleys in the big house
the attorney spoke with E.T last month
and told us the fight to get out is well
underway if Todd and Julie could share a
message with the world what do you think
they'd want them to know you know I
think they'd want folks to know that
they are the same people they've always
been that they didn't do these things
and that they're going to fight to get
their name clear